este estado le permite al gobierno local
implementar medidas urgentes las que
necesiten así como trabajar más
rápidamente con las diferentes agencias
públicas para atender la emergencia que
está viviendo la capital británica el
alcalde de londres shadi khan también ha
expresado su preocupación por la falta
de trabajadores sin precedentes de
primera línea como bomberos trabajadores
del sistema nacional de salud policías y
otros todos por contagios de kobe y es
que bajo este estado de emergencia
podríamos ver algunos bomberos
conduciendo las ambulancias y los
hospitales han advertido que no podrían
garantizar su nivel normal y es que las
cifras del gobierno indican que en 1534
personas están hospitalizadas por ccoo
bits sólo en londres con un aumento del
28 puntos seis por ciento más que la
semana pasada y en las últimas horas
también ha advertido el alcalde de
londres la capital británica ha
reportado más de 26 mil contagios una
cifra récord desde que empezó la
pandemia aquí en el reino unido- por
ello científicos han pedido al gobierno
nacional de boris johnson que decrete al
menos un confinamiento de dos semanas
desde ahora antes de navidad' para poder
limitar los contactos que tienen las
personas es decir no compartir con
quienes no viven en sus casas para
tratar de frenar
rápidamente los contagios de omicron en
todo el reino unido esta es la segunda
vez que el gobierno regional el gobierno
local de londres decreta el estado de
emergencia en la capital británica